TUCK STUCK OVER THE LAST 30
YEARS THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER HAS A POWER
FORCE.
IT HAS A LOT OF POWER AND
GETS IT BY SYSTEMATICALLY
SLAP DERG THOSE ON THE LEFT.
PRACTICE CONVENTIONAL
CHRISTIANITY BELIEVE IN THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
SEXES AND HOST A SHOW LIKE
THIS ONE AND CAN YOU EXPECT
THE SPLC TO BRAND YOU AS
EXTREMIST, HATE CRIMEA
GROUP.
THEY HAVE GOTTEN RICH DOING
IT ENDOWMENT OF
$500 MILLION.
BUT EVEN AS IT CALLED ALL OF
ITS POLITICAL ENEMIES EVIL,
THE SPLC WAS AND YOU WILL
NOT BE SURPRISED TO HEAR
THIS OPERATING ON A VERY
DIFFERENT STANDARD WITHIN
THEIR OWN OFFICES.
TODAY, THE GROUP ABRUPTLY
ANNOUNCED THE FIRING OF ITS
FOUNDER MORRIS DISEASE.
THE GROUP HAS NOT REVEALED
WHAT DIAZ DID.
STATEMENT IMPLIES BEHAVIOR
WAS SEVERE AND WIDESPREAD.
THE SPL SAID NOT ONLY FIRED
DES BRING IN OUTSIDE
INVESTIGATION TO WORK OF THE
ENTIRE GROUP.
A REPORTER CITES INTERNAL
SPLC EMAIL AND SAYS DEES WAS
FIRED FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND BUCKLE YOUR SEAT BELT
FOR THIS ONE RACIAL BIAS.
DESPITE CALLING THE GROUP
THE SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW
CENTER NOTHING IMPOVERISHED
AT ALL ABOUT HIS LIFESTYLE.
HE LIVED VERY WELL PROBABLY
BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE IN
THE STATE OF ALABAMA.
HE WAS 82.
HE WAS THE SPLC'S HIGHEST
PAID EMPLOYEE AND LIVED IN
LUXURIOUS PLACE ON A COUPLE
OF HUNDRED ACRES.
GOT RICH BY FRIGHTENING
GRAND MOTHERS SENDING THEM
DIRECT MAIL AND HURTING HIS
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
THAT PAYS WELL.
THIS EVENING DEES SPOKE WITH
A LOCAL REPORTER AND DENIED
ALL WRONGDOING.
THAT'S NOT SURPRISING.
DEES SET HIMSELF UP AS
ARBITER OF GOOD AND BAD.
HE IS BY DEFINITION A GOOD
PERSON.
YOU DISAGREE WITH HIM AND